foreign
is from Amanda in Chattanooga
hey Josh this is Amanda I'm just outside
of Chattanooga Tennessee you've
mentioned before that you have OCD I
have panic disorder which both are
anxiety disorders I'm just wondering
what are the things that you do to calm
yourself are there any natural remedies
that work for you that you don't mind
sharing
we can certainly talk about some methods
or techniques that will help in the
moment but quite often these methods are
techniques are like especially with
anxiety as our friend Dr John deloney
talks about it's like taking the battery
out of the smoke detector it doesn't
actually extinguish the fire in fact it
can make things much worse if we don't
address the root of our anxiety I was
talking to a friend recently and she
gets anxious all the time but she's
often putting herself in situations that
are heavily stimulating right and of
course we're walking around more anxious
than ever as a society because we're in
a more stimulating Society than ever
before I have an anxiety producing
machine in my pocket and it's buzzing
and reminding me that I should be
anxious In This Moment now I will say
this some people have a higher tolerance
or higher threshold Ryan it handles
Stress and Anxiety a lot better than I
do but even he has a threat threshold
and when he reaches that threshold then
of course it man the the effects of it
manifest in different ways here's what
I'll say though too Amanda specifically
what if your weakness
in quotes here what if your weakness is
actually a superpower because we often
think of OCD and some people would even
call it a mental illness and I've been
diagnosed with OCD right and so of
course that must be bad okay there are
certainly some bad parts about it right
but what if it's also a superpower what
if it's the thing that fuels me my
attention to detail enables us to do so
enables me and our whole team to do some
things that we wouldn't otherwise be
able to do if I didn't have that same
obsession with the details I saw this
Instagram video
recently someone shared it with me it
was a cat who every time they wouldn't
they were going to the bathroom
and they would jump onto the counter and
they would fix the toilet paper
dispenser if paper was was uh was
dangling down cat would just go in and
gently tidy up the paper dispenser and
the
I feel but also like I want a cat like
that like I don't want a cat for any
other reason other than it will come in
and tidy things up I never even looked
at it this way but if you were an animal
like a cat you could I could totally see
you as a cat why is this
I don't know it's uh you're you're uh
very particular in your ways we're like
I'm a dog where I'm like just love me if
he doesn't need people he's good on his
own and Josh Josh is like uh Leave Me
Alone
um unless I need some food or unless you
need me to tidy up
toilet paper with people but but great
without them yeah exactly yeah right
exactly yeah I want to talk to you about
that during our talk aboutable segment I
had a realization about myself recently
and my introversion in particular we'll
save that for the talk aboutables yeah
segment later this episode Mary here's
one thing that I do regularly and it
helps me more than anything else with
respect to my anxiety my obsessive
compulsive disorder right my obsessive
compulsive superpower here's the thing
that helps me more than anything I laugh
at the absurdity of everything because
when I see something out of place and it
really bothers me it bothers me right
but then if I laugh at it what does that
do it takes the edge off it takes the
seriousness out of it it makes me
realize that this isn't permeating the
fabric of existence it's not about the
toilet paper slightly off and therefore
that is disordered no it's only
disordered because I say that that is
out of order I have made up a story in
my mind about how things should be but
when I laugh at those shoulds I see the
Absurd I am an absurdist I laugh at
everything especially the things that
seem most serious death disease anxiety
depression I have to be able to laugh at
those things otherwise they'll crush me
yeah man I mean that's it for better or
worse like that's how you and I handle a
lot of tough situations is laughing
through it
um man I want to give Amanda a
recommendation
uh just something that I just started
using within the last like five or six
days but there's an app called neuro
cycle have you heard of this no
um I forget the doctor I forget her name
would love would love to actually have
her on the podcast
um but it starts off with her kind of
explaining like uh if you think of these
negative emotions or these negative
thoughts as like a tree and you can like
each thought is a is a tree so you've
got like the roots which is like the
cause of the thought and then the trunk
is the thought and then from the thought
you have all of these symptoms and
reactions and all these things branching
out just because of this one thought and
what she does is she really helps you
unpack it and uh yeah I would just say
Amanda like I'd highly recommend
neurocycle
um I think you can do it free for like
three or four days and it's not that
expensive either like if you want to
sign up for it but what it does is it
helps you interrupt these absurdities
that go through our mind and it helps
you present them to yourself in a
different way it gives you a different
perspective and like I said I've only
been doing it five or six days but like
each day I have learned something new
about myself that like because I could
look at all my thoughts oh that's trauma
and this is from that and you know
childhood stuff that you know whatever
it is
um but she has enabled me to dig deeper
which um you know you think you know
something
um until you find out that you don't but
yeah I would highly recommend neuro
cycle for anyone out there we'll put a
link to neuro cycle in the show notes it
is not an ad by the way uh how can we
prove it's not an ad it doesn't matter
dude use the promo code anal beads
oh man there we go for the listeners
that are curious her name is actually DR
leaf Dr Carolina Leaf it is yeah thank
you yeah Caroline Lee thank you so much
TK you want to bring this one home for
Amanda you know I would say for any
unwanted filling don't push it away let
it pass through there's an old saying
that what you resist persist and anytime
you establish an antagonistic
relationship with the filling even if
it's a really uncomfortable feeling you
tend to amplify it and make it come more
alive and then that tends to result in
this perpetuating cycle of
self-condemnation and guilt and it
increases the anxiety and what I would
say is I would try to identify if any
what are my trigger points what are
those things I tend to be doing or
thinking about when these kinds of
feelings come up and then what are the
best places for me to where are the best
places for me to be and what are the
best things for me to do while I am in
the process of letting those feelings
pass through me
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100 advertisement free
[Music]